what is up guys today I'm going to be
showing you ways you can make money in
the game of RuneScape and it's not that
hard some of these have already made
videos about but some of them I haven't
so let's get started
[Music]
[Applause]
the first method I'm gonna be showing
you guys is buying items and creating
them into sets and then selling them for
more money so here I buy all the pieces
of guthins armor set and then I sell it
for more profit so I'm going to add up
all the price of what I spent on all the
items
so one
five three mil
minus 1946 mil
or plus sorry
Plus 432.090
Plus 742k
equals 4 mil 650 000 so I made about
120k just on that one set so I'm gonna
go ahead and buy another one and do it
again
all right this one should be coming in
yep there it is
so it literally sells like I don't know
anywhere between like 30 seconds to five
minutes so it just depends
so this is like 120k every five minutes
at most so it's not that bad and then I
went ahead and sold that one
and I'm going to go ahead and buy
another one okay so this one should be
bought soon because normally people buy
each item before they make it and
there's the last piece
and so I'm gonna go ahead and do this
again and I did this a few times I did
this about five times making about 100K
each time sometimes 120k and another
armor set that I would recommend would
be all the god
D hide all the god Dragon D hide for
ranging because those sets normally go
for a lot more than they do if you buy
them individually so there's a few sets
you can do I would just look around and
test the margins that's kind of what I
do using OS buddy
and then you can figure it out another
easy and quick way to make money is
buying from NPCs in the game and as you
can see I sold this dwarf Cannon set for
791k
and now I'm going to the dwarf by the
monastery to buy another Canon set and
the only requirement for this is doing
dwarf Cannon Quest and once you do that
you can buy from this NPC by clicking on
them and then clicking spacebar and then
clicking one and then doing the spacebar
again and clicking one again and then he
will give you a full set for 750k and I
sold it for 791k sometimes 793k and I
was making anywhere from 40 to 43k on
each cell and that is insane margins it
only takes a little bit of time I did
this for an hour and made over one mil
it's super easy if you want more details
you can go look at my guide on how to do
this another MPC you can buy from is the
xamarac Mage in the wilderness and all
you have to do is hop worlds and buy
death runes from him you can make
anywhere from 750k to one mil but keep
in mind you are in the wilderness so it
is a little dangerous I made a guide on
this if you want full length details on
how to do this it is a super easy way to
make money and the only requirement is
you have to do the abyss minigame which
takes about five minutes now we will
continue on to the next method this
other method includes buying raw items
and making them into items that people
want to buy
so cooking as an example so in this case
I'm taking raw sweet corn and turning
them into sweet corn and then selling
them for profit you can do this with
sharks swordfish lobsters all depending
on when the margins are higher from the
raw to non-raw
some other examples include Fletching so
whether it be making maple long bows
from Maple logs or making Yi longbows
from e-logs or even magic longbows from
Magic logs two other options that I made
videos on are crushing bird's nests or
making crystal keys from Loop halfs and
tooth halves another raw item that you
can turn into an items that people use
is unicorn horns turning into unicorn
dust can make you profit
let's go on to the next method now
another easy way to make money is doing
farming and I know I talk about farming
a lot in my videos but I can't stress
enough how important farming is farming
is such an easy skill to do you can do
it literally once a day and that's 100K
right there I just made 100K in about
four minutes of work it's super easy you
don't need the high of a farming level
and farming is not a grind because you
can literally do it once a day if you
don't want to do it that many times and
it'll level up very fast so I highly
recommend doing this doing herb rums you
can make anywhere from 100 to 200k an
hour
and it is a very good method to do
another method I recommend is killing
things in old school RuneScape for money
so what I'm doing here is barrows
barrows is a very good way to make money
it's about 800 to 1 mil an hour when you
do it efficiently and also other
monsters I'd recommend killing are
brutal black dragons that's anywhere
from 500 to 1 mil an hour depending on
your levels and doing blue dragons and
green dragons as they range from 500 to
1 mil as well
killing things in old school RuneScape
is a very good method as well as doing
Slayer if you have a high Slayer level
you will start making a lot of money I
hope this guide helped you guys get a
little idea of how to make money easily
in the game and if you have any
suggestions for any new videos or any
tips or tricks go ahead and leave it in
the comment section below even if you
have some negative criticism go ahead
and leave it in there I reply to
everyone's comments and go ahead and
give this video a thumbs up and go ahead
subscribe alright thanks guys for
watching and stay tuned for my next
video
foreign